Speaker 1: for those who were assuming that Lauren
Boebert reelection was a foregone conclusion,
it may not be. It may not be. We have some
new polling that shows it's not as bad as
maybe it seems. Axios reporting Lauren Boebert is
reelection in jeopardy. According to a new poll
by the numbers, Boebert received support from 47%
of likely voters. Democrat Adam Frisch landed at
45. This makes the race a statistical tie within
the 4.4 plus or minus percentage point margin of
error. 7% of voters are undecided. This is a
survey from September 29 to October 2nd taken
by Keating Research. It is a Democratic firm, but
it is also one of the most historically accurate
pollsters in Colorado. This is a five point swing
towards Fresh. In July, it was Boebert 4942,
and this is a five point swing. The big
takeaway is that with Boebert under 50%,
it means she is vulnerable to losing the race.
Fresh still has a lot of work to do, but it is
something now it's important to understand. As
the Axios article points out, the third district
in Colorado overwhelmingly favors Republicans,
and it is not actually considered competitive by
national experts. Typically. Typically, this is a
situation where the undecideds swing towards the
Republican in that district. FiveThirtyEight
has one of these forecasts. It currently has
it at a 98% chance of boebert being reelected and
only a 2% chance of Adam Fresh winning. Not a lot
of polling in this one. It is worth voting if you
live in the third district of Colorado. I know we
have viewers in that area because you've emailed
me about this race vote. Do not concede it costs
you nothing to also fill out the ballot for member
of Congress. And if boebert could be defeated,
it would be a major victory for Democrats.
We will see. We will follow the race.